نبدا بالتطورات الميدانيه للحرب الروسيه
على اوكرانيا حيث قال الجيش الاوكراني ان
القوات الروسيه قصفت مقاطعات خرصون
وميكولايف وسبوجيا جنوبيه البلاد
الروسيه انها نقلت بعض قواتها في خرسون
وزافي الى خطوط خلفيه بسببك كثافه القصف
الاوكراني جديد الوضع في الجانب
الاوكرانيه
السلام خضر نبدا معك تامر الصمادي وجديد
التطورات
نعم مريم وانا انتظر هذا الهوى يعني قبل
اقل من دقيقه تجددت اصوات القصف هنا في
عمق المدينه زباروجيا وقبل اقل من نصف
ساعه من الان تجدد الانذار في المدينه
لانذار للسكان بضروره البقاء او البحث عن
اماكن امنه لان القصف متواصل يتجدد من
لحظه لاخرى منذ ساعات الصباح هنالك قصف
على مواقع مختلفه من المقاطعه بالاضافه
الى خطوط التماس بين القوات الاوكرانيه
والروسيه تتحدث عن نوعين من القصف هنالك
القصف الروسي على الكره والبلدات
الاوكرانيه كما تقول القوات الاوكرانيه
تحديدا القيادات تعمل قياده عمليات الجنوب
بالاضافه الى القصف المتبادل بين الطرفين
والحديث عن نقاط
تماس تقول السلطات بان القصف يتكثف على
منطقه
التي تسيطر عليها القوات الروسيه همم
القصف الاوكراني بالاضافه الى توك وهناك
حديث هنالك حديث عن قتلى وجرحى وتطورات
ايضا متلاحقه في خيرسون هنالك
قصف قصف متبادل على طرفي نهر دنيبر ضفتيه
نهر دنيبر بين القوات الاوكرانيه والروسيه
وهناك قصف ايضا روسي متواصل على المدينه
وفقا لقياده عمليات الجنوب الاوكرانيه
تحدثت عن ان الروس قصفه المدينه خلال
الساعات الماضيه همم اكثر من 30 مره وتقول
السلطات بان القصف يتكثف على البنيه
التحتيه على القرى والبلدات تحديدا
المناطق الماهوله بالسكان وانا اتحدث مريم
في هذه الاثناء ايضا نستمع الى صوت القصف
من تلك الجهه مره اخرى في عمق المدينه في
قلب المدينه هنالك اجراءات مشدده تفرضها
السلطات تحديدا في زبروجه لحساسيه الموقف
حساسيه المشهد تحديدا ان هنالك المحطه
المحطه الطاقه النوويه ولذلك تمنعنا من
الوصول الى اماكن القصب وتقول بانها همم
الاماكن التي تقصف هي اماكن خاصه بالقوات
الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى مناطق مدنيه ايضا
التطورات ايضا في ميكو لايف جنوب حيث
تواصل القوات الروسيه كما تقول السلطات في
اوكرانيا قصف منطقه اوتشوكا التي تغذي
ميكولايت بالمياه والتطورات نهايه في
دينيبر وتحديدا في منطقه نيكوب الحي تتعرض
لقصف مدفعي منذ ساعات الصباح وعدت هذه
اللحظه وفقا للقوات الاوكرانيه من قبل
القوات الروسيه نعم خضر ما الذي تقوله
القوات الروسيه
بالضبط مريم نبدا من ذا برج اليوم حاكم
المقاطعه المواليه لروسيا اكد في منشور له
على تليجرام ان القوات الروسيه والقوات
الموليه لها لا تزالوا متواجده في المواقع
التي تمسكها وتقوم بالسيطره عليها الرجل
يؤكد ان جميع المرافق في تلك المناطق ايضا
تعمل بشكل طبيعي سواء المرافق المدنيه من
مدارس
وادارات او حتى المرافق الطبيه من
مستشفياتهم بشكل خاص هذا ما يجري في ذا
براجيا ما يجري في همم قرب ضخم والجنوب
ضخم والتحديدا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه تقول
ان القوات
الاوكرانيه تحاول التقدم باتجاه مواقع
خسرتها جنوب المدينه ولكن القوات الروسيه
تصد هذه المحاولات ونجحت بحسب طبعا الدفاع
الروسيه باسقاطي بايقاع خسائر بالقوات
المهاجمه ودفعتها الى تراجع ما بعد منطقه
ماريان قبل مدينه بخمط مدينه بخمط لا
تزالوا بيد القوات الاوكرانيه هنا في
دانيت ايضا قالت الدفاع الروسيه ان القوات
الاوكرانيه حاولت وتحاور بشكل حثيث
تعزيز المواقع المتقدمه لديها خاصه في
منطقه افديافكا التي تتمركز فيها القوات
الاوكرانيه ولكن الوحدات الروسيه بحسب
الجانب الروسي هنا
تمنع وصول مزيدا من التعزيزات الى افديتك
الجيش الروسي يحاول منذ بضعه ايام السيطره
على افديتك والتقدم اكثر باتجاه مركز
المدينه لكنه حتى الان لم ينجح بذلك قبل
ان نستمع الى وزاره الدفاع نشروا اخيرا
الى انه في هذه الاثناء نسمع تجددا للقصف
ولكن هذه المره على ما يبدو ونظرا للصوت
المنخفض الذي نسمعه فان هناك قذائف تنطلق
من الجانب الروسي باتجاه المواقع
الاوكرانيه مجمل
بورات الميدانيه اجملتها اليوم حاطه وزاره
الدفاع الروسيه نستمع الى اليه
القوات المسلحه الاوكرانيه محاولات فاشله
لاستعادها في منطقه
وتعزيز مواقع في افديفكا ومارينكا في
جمهوريه دونيس الشعبيه ونتيجه للاستهداف
المباشر والمكثف قتل حوالي 60 جنديا
اوكرانيا وتم تدمير دبابتين وخمس مركبات
قتاليه وفي اتجاه جنوب الدمياط قام العدو
بمحاولات الهجوم المضاد في ثلاث مناطق في
جمهوريه دونيس الشعبيه لكن الضربات الجويه
الهجوميه ونرانا المدفعيه اوقفت الهجمات
الاوكرانيه واعاده المهاجمين الى مواقعهم
الاصليه وبلغت خسائر العدو في هذا الاتجاه
اكثر من 40 قتيلا وجريحا اوكرانيا وفي
كوبيانس دمر الطيران العمليات والتكيكي
ثلاثه مواقع قياده للعدو واربع 74 واحده
ونيجيجن كاميرا